good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Tuesday hope
everyone's having a great day thus far
how are you I'm good how are you no I'm
really good thank you so much for asking
how are you I'm okay what's got you down
not no nothing Tuesday Blues it's um
Tuesday Blues day it's been like a crazy
couple of weeks for me I'm headed to
Dallas tomorrow I'm running on fumes you
know yeah but the toast always has a way
of fuming me back up so that's what we
do we fumigate why don't you check back
in at the end of the show okay I bet you
I'll be doing better I probably won't
even remember to check back in because I
will have already forgotten that you
were so unwell because you'll be doing
so amazingly at the end of the show and
that's it I know I couldn't even fathom
you not having been amazing a mere 50
minutes prior Jackie that's beautiful I
like your pants you look cute today
thanks I ordered some clothes from Asos
maternity so I'm just kind of like
wearing all of them at the same time
that's so important that when you open a
package of clothes that are supposed to
be like your seasonal wardrobe that you
wear them all at once the first day yeah
so I got some like slit leggings like
turdy wears but they're maternity
maternity maturity and this big t-shirt
which like could be cool I needed like
some necklaces yeah you know what I
think I do
um no no come on be a good tip oh okay
like you're so gorgeous and skinny like
give me a [__] necklace okay like
fine here and I'm only giving this
necklace because because it's my I
invented it because Jackie got the
necklace and then I bought it and copied
it so I was like thinking that's what I
needed to like make this outfit more of
an outfit and less of like just clothes
a big shirt okay it looks great on you
looks cool yeah feeling so bare it's
fine no it's good you're like you're
simple and low-key today and while we're
talking about our fashion inspiration
let's talk about your pants
thank you no no like we need to talk
about your pants oh you don't like them
no remember you bought them no I did in
the fitting room I didn't let me tell
you what happened wow are those not the
ones from the fitting room they're a
dupe
right because they were so expensive you
couldn't I'm sorry Alice and and Olivia
I need to talk to both of you I tried on
like cute silk trousers I was like let
me try something new I'm always wearing
like athleisure pants leggings flared
you know slit plant plant pants
I said Tony let's try something new and
I just picked up these like Silk
trousers from Allison Olivia they were
so cute they were like cargo pants like
Pockets up and down the side and they
literally called Jack you were going in
on the big pants Trend yes I called
Jackie I was like am I crazier do these
look amazing she was like no they look
amazing
600 I didn't say that what I didn't say
they looked amazing I was really
uncertain of them
that's not how I remember it going down
that's so funny how perception is
everything maybe I was just like I'm so
overly confident then like you only
heard me say that you weren't even
listening to what I said yeah what did
you say like I just wasn't sure about
them because they're super trendy yeah I
wouldn't personally like really know how
to style them but I was like you are on
your own style Journey turdy Lou so I
then went online and I like searched the
pants maybe you know the real real had
them or maybe like somebody was just
putting them on sale on you know some
turnt website thread right or no like
you know list.com is always like you can
buy them here for a dollar from the
Netherlands
nothing then I searched dupe
Allison Olivia you say it right it's a
it's a tick tock Trend okay where it's
like you pick something up and you're
like Chanel poop because like people got
like dupe cultures so out of control
like look at this dupe oh my God so The
Tick Tock girls will get it and I found
these Zara ones they were like 50 bucks
and they look you thought they were the
Allison I did they look exactly the same
Zara Zara whatever you call it and
you're like in the trouser life I'm Pro
trouser in general I like a nice pant
yeah I I am I need to see how I
photograph how I film but
it's nice to change it up yeah it is
nice to change it up elastic waistband
I'm in you know
you look nice I can't believe you
thought I was wearing the real thing I
would have never known shouldn't have
told me no it's okay I'm proud of my
dupe
seriously I'm a proud doopy dupe girl
that's really crazy I know I can't
believe you thought they were out
you know so we're just both in our new
in our new Garb in our new Garb um I got
a couple other things from Asos
maternity one dress like how to stain ew
like I think I think it was someone
postpartum because it was like looked
like a milk stain and it was in this
spot that's sweet but don't [__] send
it back no of course maybe to me maybe
it's a design Choice like a maternity no
because I got it in like another color
the other color I had no milk I didn't
even open that one because I knew I
would like it so much but I didn't check
first thing there was no way it was
gonna happen twice okay rank maternity
clothes like where to shop yeah
literally just keep wearing the biggest
things in your closet uh I don't really
love I haven't found stumbled upon
um maternity clothes that I'm passionate
about but in last pregnancy in this
pregnancy I ordered from Asus maternity
like for
Basics like leggings they have really
nice leggings like they're so stretchy
stretchy like you don't feel the band
The tightness yeah uh
uh and like t-shirts like this is a
maternity t-shirt so it's like it's it
has a little more give in the belly
belly is important
um I also just ordered from hatch which
is like the maternity shop the go-to the
go-to they had like some really nice
pieces it was a little more expensive so
I'm really excited to get it to see if
it was like worth the money they had
sent me some stuff in my last pregnancy
that I did like
um and then I just I I bought I checked
out the whole website they did a
collaboration with Free People movement
so for like of leisure and some stuff is
really cute so I'm hoping that it looks
cute on me you know I actually just
ordered from free people I got so
influenced by a whole Ariel charnis to
it did you see it she just like they
hear Ariel selects it's like oh great a
fabulous person is shopping on the
website for me and I bought like four
things great loved it I'm so susceptible
to being influenced you know what I was
influenced by what this Amazon live I
watched last night oh my God the time of
my life I always see influencers doing
Amazon live like I've seen Madison
liqueur do them Paige disorder does them
all the time and Myanmar were asked to
do one since we're working with Amazon
this week to go to the ACM Awards and I
was nervous yeah how nice for you guys
that's really fun
I was nervous I'm not gonna always have
an amazing time it's an hour long and
there were like a lot of rules it's not
like lawlessness here at the toes where
we could say whatever we want you know
obviously we couldn't curse and we were
you know showcasing a lot of different
items for travel and Beauty so there
were like certain things negative about
exactly or about anything right which is
hard you don't want to sell negativity
no
um it was so much fun uh a lot of people
from the toast tune in which I really
appreciate it was like nice to be
amongst like like-minded people I
watched it while I got ready this
morning just kind of relive the magic
yeah I watched it while it was live but
I couldn't be plugged in for the whole
thing and then later that night I
started it again it was funny right like
it was really good we were being like
crazy and you guys had really good
select yeah we did and we both like had
we're wearing full outfits from Amazon
that were really cute I've got a cart
full of stuff I haven't placed my order
yet but I was influenced to get that gym
bag I know Margo stole it from set
oh I was like who's Seth Seth sorry oh
damn I'll steal from her yeah and I'll
give you guys the affiliate commission
yeah make sure I have an Amazon
storefront now and the merch there was
like a Luke Combs t-shirt that was like
super cool that's like my maternity
go-to Amazon has you know I can get I
can see if I can pull some strings get
you some free merch yeah yeah I really
liked that yeah they have um ACM
exclusive merch which is cool because I
like it and then I was also inspired to
click the Norma Kamali tab because I
loved your dress and she has great
stretchy clothes I feel like the dress
that I wore is like a cute maternity
like the belly yeah maybe I could try it
yeah take it for me okay I already took
like a million pictures in it it's yours
I need to go shopping in your closet I
know well you were saying like you know
the best thing to wear for maternity is
just the biggest thing in your clothes
or your formerly fat sister yeah like I
have so much clothing no I keep asking
to like bring me stuff yeah
you know you're compromising like
comfort for style yeah but also like
they think with maternity clothes that
it's just your belly that gets big and
no blessed to all the women who go
through that noon
blessing seven blessings on your head
but like for the rest like what about
the breasts where am I supposed to put
my breasts the hips the thighs like it's
everything and they say like shop your
pre-pregnancy size and it's like let it
just get a belly I'm not like your model
who put on a fake belly right photo
shoot right oh speaking of something but
it's an impossible situ like it's not
even like I feel like there needs to be
a clothing brand that's that makes
better maternity clothes it's like we
all are shaping up differently yeah in
this experience and you just have to
clothe yourself and get through
maternity clothing is more personal than
comedy
literally by the way something that we
spoke about on the toast yesterday that
I wanted to just quickly talk about
um is the conspiracy theory about Taylor
Swift's book because I know then you or
it piqued your interest and you I saw
some more compelling reasons why they
think it's hers but dumois posted that
it is a music artist who's coming out
with the book but what Dumas has heard
is that it's like a a big International
um singing group makes you think like
BTS the way she described it
um yeah which would be like an enormous
disappointment yeah I don't think it's
BTS together right now if it's anyone
but Taylor like it would be an enormous
disappointment yeah because I've like
now gotten comfortable
with the idea that Taylor's writing a
book like I'm so so here were the other
clues that people shared with us the
length of pages is 544 adds up to 13.
the audiobook is 13 hours the announce
date is June 13th like that's the day
like you just changed your the
announcement date like when they say the
name and title and author and then it
comes out I think July 9th or July 7th
July 7th to speak now oh okay so then
July 9th like in my eyes literally
um so those are compelling reasons and
also someone said like the All Too Well
music video she ends it as an author but
like she also plays uh
Cinderella in the yeah like she has a
million music yeah yeah yeah no you like
when she puts out as much content as she
does you could really pick a reference
for many of them and make it work for
your theory right so that one is a
little bit lighter I
it's compelling but it honestly sounds
too good to be true I mean maybe it's
Britney's Memoir but we already have
like all that detail we actually have a
story about it today because there's a
lot of drama he's there yeah there's a
lot of Britney drama period today yeah
there's a lot of Brittany drama every
day and honestly I don't really read
into it yeah because it's a dark dark
hole and you get LED I saw Ben showed me
he's like did you see this Tick Tock and
it was like one of Britney's dancing
videos slowed down and in the video she
covers her face with her hands and
before she covers her face with her
hands she has a smokey eye when she
takes it off really quickly there's no
smokey eye and then eventually the
smokey eye comes back and everyone's
like it's an AI generated video of
Brittany she's not doing well and
they're making fake content I'm like no
that's literally just how fillers work
filters work like when on Tick Tock when
you cover your eyes and there's like a
makeup filter on it obviously takes the
makeup off and then when you uncover
your eyes it just takes a second to
adjust who cares no it was that's what
I'm saying and you go it's like a Time
waster those Britney conspiracy theory
holes like I can't get into it so I
really don't follow a lot of what's
going going on with Brittany that was my
original point
wow those are like maybe 45 seconds I
won't get back no but I had to
experience it so therefore you do too
I
but I'm looking forward to hearing what
Britney's going through yeah yeah just
re her book yeah read her book which I
feel like we've been talking about for a
long time yeah and I'm sure some of the
stories you're going to deliver maybe
explain why they're delayed yes in
addition to there being a paper shortage
that was the first reason why I didn't
know that that was a while ago that
sounds like a lie everyone else's book
is coming out right right no one's
delayed but the special paper Britney
needs is delayed yeah
um
yeah I don't think this book is ever
coming out we'll get to it that's a very
good like stance to take I don't think
that's entirely impossible yeah
um so yeah we've got a great show
yesterday's episode was so fabulous I
just like I watched it a thousand times
I'm sure because then you could relive
arrows again yeah and I watched my own
Vlog up on patreon 45 000 times
um and everyone's loving the Vlog so
patreon.com if you want all the behind
the scenes tea about era's weekend in
Nashville yeah it's a really fun watch
and I feel like maybe like we could jump
in it's like so crazy for us only to
jump in after 12 minutes oh my gosh
anything else we want to talk about well
I just wanted to shout out to Amazon
while we were talking about your live
stream for the Kindle gift I brought it
for you will you actually grab it from
my purse a dirty Lou when Margo and I
got to our Green Room at the Amazon live
yesterday there was a gift there for us
it took us like a second to figure out
what it was and they made one for Jackie
too it is the new Kindle it's called the
Kindle scribe it's bigger than my head
Kindle scribes it's huge it's really
like a home and now like your regular
paper right is like your travel Kindle
yeah and they bedazzled the back for us
with our initials Jackie's has a big
pink J on it I brought it for you it's
dead sorry
um it's heavy isn't that so cool like ah
the perfect gift doesn't exist yes it
does I read on mine last night I
finished the social climber which is a
book that you recommended and you didn't
love it I liked it like if I don't love
a book I won't finish it so if I finish
a book I like it
um I found it to be like a little
predictable a little long it was
predictable it was like she wasn't
trying to hide it it was just you were
putting everything together really
slowly but she was telling you yeah do
you see the twist at the end about yes
there were so many Easter eggs about
like the drinking like oh like I think
one thing about me like I'm dumb as
rocks like but I can figure out a
thriller the thing is I don't try like
unless The Thrillers take me a really
long time to finish I don't try to
figure it out like I just sort of let it
be let it be but I did start the new
Sally hepar of the book last night um
sucked me right in oh good let me know
how it is to write it because that's
going to be my selection for book club
I'm only like five percent but I'm
sucked Sally Hepworth is a sucker yeah
she'll suck you right in so I'll keep
you posted but enjoy the new Kindle it's
nice to be sucked in the charger and the
power button are on the side left your
other side charging on my Kindle because
it got used to your Kindle instead of
mine and it's a USBC charger so the same
one you use for your laptop
yeah so it was a really good so excited
no and I'm just like so excited that I
got one because obviously like it was
you were feeling left out yeah it was
like your instinctious experience like
it was just so generous that you guys at
Amazon thought of me like seriously
thank you I would have been depressed if
you guys got well like I only got a
Kindle because you introduced me to
Kindles so it wouldn't be right no wait
it wouldn't be right but it could have
been what happened no but the universe
wouldn't have allowed something so
egregious you and Margo would have had
to hide ears and never let me know that
they would have had to like contact
whoever company who bedazzled it and had
another one made
they shipped it to your house in Florida
you'll get it later
literally literally but need not occur
no so thank you you're welcome
now I feel like without further Ado here
are the past five stories that you need
to know and today's episode is brought
to you by neutralfall did you know that
30 Willie Willian did you
did you know that 30 million women are
impacted by weekend or thinning hair if
you're among them no you're not alone
and there's a solution that you can
trust to deliver results Jax and I are
two of those 30 million you know yours
was caused by pregnancy postpartum mine
was caused by like a recent change in
diet it is so isolating it is the worst
feeling like when you realize that it's
happening to you like you have to cry
but neutralfall is the number one
dermatologist recommended hair growth
supplement that is clinically proven to
clinically shown to improve your hair
growth thickness and visible scalp
coverage neutrophone supports healthy
hair growth from within by targeting
those root causes of thinning which can
be stress hormones environment nutrition
and Metabolism through whole body health
they have three unique formulas at
neutrophone to support women throughout
all stages uh including postpartum and
menopause each formula is physician
formulated using natural drug-free
medical grade ingredients and it is
consistently effective in dosaging so
you get the most reliable results 86 of
women in a clinical study reported
improved hair growth after six months
when I was like freaking when I realized
like I was having major hair thinning
and also shedding I immediately asked
like people in my life and I think I
also asked my Instagram followers like
what to do and so many people
recommended neutrophone you can grow
thicker healthier hair and support our
show by going to nutrifall.com entering
promo code toast and saving 10 on your
first month's subscription this offer is
only available to you as customers for a
limited time plus free shipping on every
order so that's ten dollars off at
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com neutrophone.com
promo code toast today's episode is also
brought to you by Sundays Sundays for
dogs is air dried dog food made from a
short list of human grade ingredients
Sundays was co-founded by Dr Tory who's
a practicing veterinarian and contains
90 percent meat 10 vegetables and zero
percent synthetic nutrients so if you've
been wanting to switch out your dog's
food for something healthy something
fresh check out Sundays it's made with
um digestive AIDS like pumpkin and
ginger disease fighting antioxidants and
of course USDA beef and all-natural
chicken dog parents are reporting
noticeable Health improvements when
switching their dogs to Sundays like
softer fur fresher breath better poops
more energy and it just feels so good as
two dog moms we know how good it feels
to switch your pup to the best quality
food and that is Sundays unlike other
fresh dog food there's zero prep with
Sundays there's zero mess so of course
zero stress Sundays is shelf stable it
makes it easy to feed your pup top
quality food and top quality fabric
every order ships right to your door
you'll never worry about running out of
dog food and it's affordable they cost
40 less than other Healthy dog food
brands because Sundays doesn't waste
money shipping Frozen packages instead
they send they spend on what matters
which is sourcing the best all-natural
ingredients for your pup and we've
worked out a special deal for our dog
loving listeners get 35 off your first
order of Sundays when you go to Sundays
for dogs.com toast or just use co-host
at checkout so that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com
sundays4dogs.com forward slash toast
upgrade your pup to Sundays and feel
good about the food that you're feeding
your dog your dog your dogs are gay your
dogs are straw fans that's true they are
and they're brass and Tracy yeah I don't
even want to get into this first first
story it's so crushing story is like the
closest we've ever needed to having an
emergency episode of the toast yesterday
yeah
um we've never had an emergency episode
I don't know if we ever will but I
really considered it yes it was so
devastating Soul crushing when news
broke that Kim Zolciak Biermann has
filed for divorce from Kroy Biermann Kim
is pulling the plug on her marriage
filing for divorce from Croy on the
heels of the couple's Financial
struggles according to legal docs
obtained by TMZ the real houses of
Atlanta Star lists April 30th as the
date of separation between her and the
former NFL star the two were married for
11 years and have four kids together
during that time plus Kroy adopted
kids two daughters so in total they're
six oh my God there's so many layers to
this that are so devastating like I'm
such a believer in Kim and croy's love I
feel like I've followed their Journey
for so many years from Atlanta to Don't
Be Tardy and he was such a good husband
and she was like so happy and I feel
like you know it was such a fairy tale
and he adopted the girls and I'm
devastated like I'm so bereft I don't
there are no words I know she's said
she's filing because the marriage is
quote irretrievably broken with no hope
of reconciliation which is Court words
you know you have to check something so
that's the Box yeah she's asking for
primary physical custody of the kids and
Joint legal custody she also wants
spousal support and to legally restore
her maiden name also yesterday it broke
on TMZ that Kim and Croy owe over one
million dollars to the IRS in unpaid
taxes interests and penalties from 2013
2017 and 2018 and they also owe the
state of Georgia fifteen thousand
dollars from unpaid taxes in 2018. it
was reported
a few months ago that their house was in
foreclosure in February but and then
like the day it was supposed to
foreclose they like paid the bills and
like Brielle and Ariana denied that that
was true they were talking to the paps
um so that was always that was unclear
there's always been like very Financial
Cloud curiosity yeah above them
um so then the million dollars owed to
the IRS
yesterday same day as the divorce does
make me question like perhaps this is a
you know uh
strategic Financial move I don't know I
don't see how this could benefit either
one of them no but like this is
literally similar to like when Erica
Jane announced her divorce a lot of
people just just assumed it was because
all of his it was because of all of his
legal troubles that ended up not being
true yeah
no but it was like I'm just grasping at
straws like looking for anything there's
no way these two aren't going to be
together forever I know it's really
really sad I'm imagine that the
financial hardships have put a strain on
their relationship but I thought that
they're the type that could get through
anything and like Kim would just be like
even if it was like croy's fault that
the taxes didn't get paid maybe he was
in charge of like taxes in their house
like she would be like I stand with
crying
or die we'll make the million but you
know your show they they haven't like I
don't know in terms of income
where they're getting it from like he no
longer plays in the NFL they're no
longer reality stars on Bravo and they
influence and stuff but they live a very
lavish life but couldn't she just like
call Andy no and be back on Atlanta oh
on Atlanta yeah
for a big paycheck everyone would love
to have I would simply pass away like
yeah I don't know I don't know if that's
an option I think you meant Don't Be
Tardy no because that like if people
don't want to watch your show they don't
want to watch your show I can't relate
to those people but yeah people who
didn't watch Don't Be Tardy like just
will never know what an absolute Joy it
was like even towards the end when like
I think their ratings were dwindling and
they got like a little desperate for
story lines and they like went on like a
family RV trip around the country you
never saw better TV in your life like
this is a family and now that the
younger kids are like getting older I
would love for it to come back this is a
family like prepped and primed for
reality television
towards the end like it was not like
alcohol let's come to an end but it was
still good why not real housewives if
she needs a job like I feel like that's
always waiting for her oh you know what
I never even thought of that I don't
know I don't know I have to assume yeah
and like in one season she could pay the
billion yeah and her and Craig could get
back together has nobody over there
thought of this yeah no maybe maybe it
hasn't come up
like no one's thought of it thought of
it yeah no it's a really good idea until
problem solved I'm fully living in
denial like until I hear more like until
Corey's out of the house like I will not
believe it yeah they're so in love and
they're so physically attracted to one
another and they like love each other so
much and they have this big ass family
like there's no [__] way I feel like
something had to have happened because I
feel like she would have they would have
pushed through anything anything
again also what does this mean as like
for Croy as like a father to Ariana and
Brielle yeah
what does it mean
he did adopt them I think it just
depends on their relationship first yeah
like you know what I mean yeah yeah do
crate do something bad misbehave right
or they just have they've grown apart I
don't like I can't see how that happened
but you know sometimes it's like soul
mates don't grow apart I know they don't
like the six kids no and yeah
I'm upset like I'm so upset I know you
are
and if only cameras were rolling we'll
never know
I feel like we will know because they're
all public figures they're all kind of
open books and they're
Fame is also wrapped up in their
personal lives So eventually like they
will share in one format or another
Maybe
maybe we're having a hard time getting
Kim cast back on Real Housewives of
Atlanta maybe for the paycheck she even
wanted and now like a global Scandal
like this a divorce will you know bring
her up a few notches and then
get her more money I'm just spitballing
here it's a good theory my only hole
with it is like filing for divorce for
that is a little extreme she could have
either leaked a rumor about her divorce
or filed for sex or separation like to
file for divorce goodbye good day sir no
but also it says their data separation
is April 31st that's literally five days
ago yeah
what does it mean April 30th because
April 31st isn't a date on the calendar
one thing about me I will never know 30
days past September April June and
November all the rest of 31 except for
February which is 28th you don't know
that riddle
30 days past September what does that
mean
include September and the months that
have 30 days
30 days with September April June and
November
all the rest have 31. I don't need that
last part I'm not a [__] [__] like I
know February is 28 my God
that's a wholly unnecessary yeah I know
leap years too that is a wholly
unnecessary part of the riddle like that
is her actual brain dead morons and
you're not there no I'm not there okay
like please give me a little respect
like I know that okay cool yeah see
learn something new and just like a fun
fact about me is like I really do
understand leap years like why we have
them do you prefer months that have 30
days or 31 days
so much going on in my life like I don't
think about that to you with patreon I
prefer 31. yeah more time to get the
content gives it it's a real like makes
a difference the month feels so short
when it's 30. I guess it just depends
like I'm having a bad month 30. I'm
having a good month 31 and depends what
month we're entering like I want to get
there right right is there something
exciting coming up or am I dreading
something in June like April to may like
I'm ready to get to May
made a Jew no actually I disagree no
April and May are like the best weather
it's like April May and June they go by
so fast and the next thing you know it's
like we're dying of heat in the summer
April's overrated I disagree
what's your favorite mom
my favorite month
shut up my favorite month it's December
because it's coldest well yeah it's
actually not coldest in December no no
December I love Christmas time like it's
there's so much holiday joy and spirit I
just love it you're the holiday cheer
Meister um I am the holiday cheer
Meister we also always take like our
annual family vacation and usually in
December it's an exciting time nobody's
working like everyone's just like kind
of decided most time off we have during
the whole year yeah and everyone has
time off so it's just like exciting yeah
what's your favorite month well you make
a really good case for December now
um but I feel like October is always a
good vibe but it's a spooky Vibe oh my
God it's so spooky yeah quaking but no
it's like a Chili Vibe it's yeah we're
entering into that festive time of year
it's all ahead of us that's good I like
that my birthday's ahead of us like I
spend like I find myself many times
throughout the year being like oh wow
holiday season is upon us yeah like I so
look it's not normal like how much and I
don't even celebrate like the holiday
Christmas I just love the whole holiday
cheer and I really wait all year long
for October November December wait in a
year for October November December what
is that
we're waiting all day for Sunday night
that did not sound at all like what you
just sang I feel like it did I feel like
it didn't
we'll Circle back just send off in the
comments did you know what Jackie was
singing
the bar for engagement is so low
no honestly I'm like I'm really upset I
know I'm trying to distract you about
Kim and cartel what's your favorite
month
I think it's sparred spurred interesting
combo I think was one of your better
questions
[Laughter]
no one's ever asked like I've never
thought about it what's your favorite
color
my favorite color
like I don't have a favorite color like
I think so you no no like I'm not trying
to be pick me no not indecisive I think
like having a favorite color is quite
possibly like the dumbest thing oh for
sure but you asked me no I know it's
just like a thing but I don't like make
it my personality like my favorite color
no I'm not but just like to have one
like why are all humans required to have
a favorite color I don't think they're
required but it's like what do you
gravitate towards like that gym bag from
your Amazon live it comes in every color
which one do you like well it just
depends you know well it's just
different for the gym mat because I did
like the cream but like I wouldn't say
cream is my favorite color right even
though you're wearing a cream shirt no
I'm like I'm Cream shoes I'm obsessed
with cream these days all roads lead to
cream creamy Vibes sad beige
sad but then I have to right because
it's that beige
um so Kim and cry we're sending you so
much love there's nothing you guys can't
work through and just know like the
country's rooting for you yeah we were
rooting for you we were all rooting for
you we're still rooting for you how dare
you no no we're still rooting for you
I'm not gonna like I'm sure it's a
really hard time like I'm not gonna make
it harder by being upset with them
because I'm sure when you're a public
figure it's like not only do you have to
like process your divorce and you hate
your husband whatever but it's like
letting people down yes but you like
yeah I don't want to add to that I'm
just
refusing to believe until I know more I
think that's a pretty good stance to
take I that's my typical one yeah and
then you come to find out like lala and
Randall then you start hating the
relationship so much because you find
out the truth about it yeah it makes
partying with it very easy wait I saw
something yesterday I just wanted to
double check before
you know the picture of Taylor Swift and
Matt Healy people are saying to say I
generated but I don't I've only seen
that in the comment section like but
every publication is still posting it I
know I was thinking about that before I
went to bed because people were
commenting that the Taylor Swift Matty
Healy picture was AI generated and it
really it made me want to have a
conversation about AI we had one last
but let's have another one because if
even like reputable news outlets can't
decipher between what's AI generated and
what's actual news like there is quite
literally no hope for our our world yeah
like we're [__] yeah that's amongst
some of the problems but the good news
is is that um AI actually attempted to
do an episode of the toast and failed
abysmaline and it was so terrible like I
feel really I have feel like I have job
security we saw toaster who did like an
AI generated episode of the toast and it
was like this script and it was so dumb
and not funny like I've never felt more
secure in my life literally I told you I
actually
a bad AI
system no or like which episodes were
they learning from right obviously not
the current one no
maybe like but then it's like AI you're
not even up to date right what are you
doing so I just think like I think the
picture is real you do I have no idea I
do
okay because I like it that's so fair
that's not why I think it's real I know
but like I think
we would know if it was AI it's so crazy
this AI thing
huh maybe there'll be an AI turdy soon
no [__] way
that would be good you could be here
there everywhere nobody would ever
replicate the OG turdy OG turkey greater
than AI turdy
ain't that the truth
are you ready for our next story yeah
like I need to move on from this
toxicity yeah moving on because Britney
Spears is brutally honest book has been
delayed over concerns from a-listers
so the sun reported on Sunday that it
sounds like a lie
Britney's publisher assignment and
Schuster receives strongly worded legal
letters from those who fear what the
singer has written quote Britney is
brutally honest in the book there are a
lot of nervous a-listers and Insider
told the outlet strongly worded legal
letters have been sent to the Publishers
by people who know Brittany and who fear
what she has written The Source added
that not only is there no movement on
the book at the moment but there are
also new concerns over when it will
eventually be able to come out although
the report didn't name names
um some famous Justin Timberlake
surrounding her are Justin Timberlake
Kevin Federline she has a lot of A-list
friends I don't think they're the ones
writing letters like Paris Hilton right
Madonna Selena I don't believe this like
I feel like there's significant delays
with her book due to ongoing you know
trauma in her life I feel like and
they're trying to give us like
legitimate reasons like the paper
shortage now this like but I don't think
that these are real
I think if anybody's writing legal
letters it would be members of her
family yeah be careful what you write
yeah
um but I just don't think a book is
forthcoming I feel like she's so not in
work mode on writing a book I don't
think she should be focused on writing a
book like I feel like that's what the
world feels like is you know what she
should have should do next in the
publishing houses like scooped it up
like
I don't think this is happening me
neither and I don't think it's because
of legal letters there's also like a
documentary or like a
show coming out or like one episode show
about like Britney's
post-conservatorship life it's like
called the price of Freedom oh and it's
it's not good in terms of what like
what's the in terms of showing what
she's like up to and that she's not
doing well
I think we would all agree she's not
doing well yeah
but she but I think we all know that but
we also like you're able to like live
your life and not be doing well and be
free what some people consider weird but
not have to be like on lithium and in a
conservation where you like don't even
have keys to your car and right people
are like shoving a diaphragm in your
room right right right right right like
this is still a free country
yeah yeah no this book I I actually
agree with your take like I don't think
we'll ever see the light of day I don't
even I feel like it could possibly not
even be written yet like and they're
just like making this stuff up because
we announced like two years ago a big
Advance here Brittany Brittany went to
Simon and Chester and we keep updating
and there's no book yeah there's no book
and I don't think there actually is
currently a book so you know page six
and all these Outlets are being fed
fraudulence
yeah that's what I think
or it's the publisher themselves by your
time sure somebody probably show them
time yeah I think that's it
I'm just like I can't even think about
this book because like I'm so convinced
there's a tail like even if the book
comes out like I honestly I don't know
that I would read it because I'm not
sure I don't know that I could be
convinced separate he wrote it no yeah
by the way that's also a really good
point like I think we all we all know
like she's just like not even because
like I don't think she could like write
a book I think if she really wanted to
100 she could she's like an artist she
has a lot to say she's uninterested
she's uninterested a hundred percent I
think you know what's not being said
like about the whole Britney discourse
is like we're watching Brittany and it's
like this is clearly a person who's
deeply unwell and we love her and we
support her and we're happy she's free
but like there has to be some sort of
you know
brutal honesty when talking about
Brittany and I think somebody you know
in her
condition right now and also just like
after what she's been through it's not
sitting down to write a 400 page book no
and also like she writes really long
Instagram captions so if she were to
write a book I'm sure they would be like
in a similar vein and that's why a lot
of editing not what I want to read and
then if it actually was like more
um
traditionally coherent or whatever I'd
be like well Brittany didn't write that
right it would be it's hard to believe
yeah yeah and I'm sure she is writing
with someone I think that's totally fine
yes
but we always say like the key most
celebrities work with like editors or
ghost writers but like the best ones
really are able to mimic the celebrity's
voice that was my problem with Mariah
Carey's book I could not for the life of
me believe that she was like speaking
that way it was just not her voice like
we know her but I thought Jessica
Simpson whoever helped her write her
book mimicked her voice to a t uh
Jeanette McCurdy wrote her own book
because she is like a writer and there
was no way she did it a girl same with
Josh pack it was so I don't know if he
worked with the writer but it was so
Josh Peck like it was so like you know
Jewish boy from New York like it was
such so his tone same attorney's book
same attorneys can literally hear her
speaking it because like I talk in a
very
um conversational and distinct way and
that was the tone of the book as well I
felt the same about Paris Hilton's book
I could hear her in my ear I haven't
read a celebrity Memoir in so long when
you like you'll get back into it really
quickly and then you'll be like
thirsting for more like Matthew actually
that's not true I read both Jeanette and
Josh Peck's last year but before that
it's been so long Andy Cohen is on like
his book tour his book tour comes his
book third Diaries I think it's called
the daddy Diaries come out it's so crazy
how like Andy's books were like the
first and only books I read and I'm like
kind of like not like that interested in
reading it yeah but I probably will
let us know keep us posted I will
so that's where Brittany's at with her
book a whole bunch of nothing yeah
are you ready for our next story yeah
Diana Agron is responding to a
decade-long and wildly untrue
speculation about her Taylor Swift
relationship so the former Glee star is
clearing the air about her relationship
with Taylor Swift in an interview with
rolling stone on Sunday the actress was
asked about being included in the linear
notes for Swift song 22 which led fans
to believe that they were involved
romantically at the time she said Me O
if only she said of being the
inspiration for for the song that's more
because of a friendship than being the
inspiration for the song but I would not
be the person to ask about that I cannot
claim that when asked directly how she
felt about being in a rumored
relationship with Swift at the time wow
this [__] reporters got balls I know
she said quote that is so interesting I
mean there have been many stories about
my dating life that are so wildly untrue
that's funny so it's in either confirmed
nor denied right it's a very bizarre um
Middle Ground response I can't believe
somebody finally just had the nerve to
ask like these are these theories that
have been swirling around on the
internet people like breaking down like
the most minute little detail and this
supporter just woke up and was like What
if I just call Diana up yeah and that's
exactly what she did yeah and we got we
honestly got less Clarity than before I
didn't know that 22 was the song I've
always known she's in the notes for 22
but also so are Ashley having known
Claire kisslinger and Selena Gomez oh
um I know that like the song that the
the the Taylor fans who believe that her
and Agron were in a relationship
um
believe the song Wonderland on 1989 is
about Diana didn't you flash your green
eyes at me I know my green Ruby comes
with a Cheshire Cat smile they are green
and she does have a Cheshire Cat smile
but I forget why the whole theme is like
Alice in Wonderland and there's some
connection I forget why there was a
compelling argument made like about why
Wonderland was a Diana Agron potential
song then they're you know they were
close for a little while and then like
never to be seen again and then there
was that tweet you know Taylor was like
when Taylor was really active on Twitter
she was like oh my God at Diane Aggron
told me that tonight's episode of Glee
they're doing one of my songs and then
like that episode didn't air an episode
of Taylor songs it was like it's like a
there if you go down the rabbit hole
which honestly I don't encourage it's so
toxic there's compelling stuff I just
want to say nothing you've shared right
here because I'm sharing half bits I
can't recall okay okay because I've
moved on with my life okay there's like
a whole sect of the fandom that like
believes Taylor was in a relationship
with Diana Agron with Carly Kloss with
her old fiddling I've seen the the Carly
claw stuff there's a lot of a lot of
stuff on Carly close but I think that's
because Taylor writes a lot of songs
about her relationship with Carly Kloss
it was like this Whirlwind two-year
friendship like best like sisters and
then nothing and then like the Betrayal
of a lifetime you know what was the
Betrayal
Scooter Braun like you know because her
husband
is like a part of like the scooter Bron
Carlisle group like money thing yeah
that's a problem when the words about of
a sister come back and Whispers that
proof she was not
okay there's a lot
a lot yeah there's a lot there
um it's really crazy that someone asked
an Android about this no it's literally
like next level especially because Diana
Agron is not publicly like an out person
right she's hetero as far as we know so
it's like kind of like that's why nobody
has asked up until this point because
it's a line you don't cross like yeah
and it's actually like a [__] up thing
and I'm surprised it was a rolling stone
yeah it's like not getting more backlash
like the reason why there are conspiracy
theories is because you don't ask people
about this because unless they're out
yeah it's none of your [__] business
whether she was in a relationship with
someone so it's like it's actually like
low-key like a really depraved thing to
do but like I respect the hustle I guess
inevitable right terrible I don't know I
don't know I don't know either but I
think she handled the questions very
beautifully by just giving us a word
salad and leaving us more confused than
before but also open to the possibility
of it being true let me tell you
something about that Diana Agron she's
like a star she's kind of like low-key
since clay she's very much like in the
art Fashion World
um and she recently got married can you
look up to somebody like with with an
important background you know okay Diana
I just saw a tick tock about Ed
and actually met her she was a delight
like I was introducing this person was
like you know Claudia is like a Gleek
which was so embarrassing she couldn't
have been nicer more delightful a girl
I'd never met you know she's married to
was married to Winston Marshall and he
was the banjo ass and lead guitarist of
Mumford and Son yes yes yes and now
who's she married to she's with someone
new no she is I don't think so I feel
like I saw she got married and was like
so classy but I often just make things
up no but she did get married in 2016.
they divorced in 2020. that's like so
Diana aggro I'm like Mumford and Sons
you know her partner or Harold and cart
and who's he it's looking artsy he's a
Belgian painter and a sculptor see she's
so like artsy now but it's just listed
as partner oh so they're not married
maybe like you know domestic whatever
yeah or maybe like boyfriend
this panel just lists like a partner
like a not spouse is a partner right
right
so I just feel like you know there's
actually a lot and she's in something
coming up I'm sure that's what she's
doing press for I think we're about to
see like the Resurgence of Diana Agron I
just want to say I'm incredibly here for
it and don't forget about her role in
Burlesque
oh my God I did forget about her role in
Burlesque well she's one of the girls no
she's the like [__] fiance oh my god
of the bartender yes yeah not kill
that's not Kellen Watts it's bull chick
they're the literal same person yeah the
guy Kellen Lutz who plays Emmett in
Twilight gives major Vol chick from the
OC Vibes but the guy from but what's Vol
chick's name his name it doesn't matter
his name is volcik from the OT
he's always playing like the bad boy
what is his name uh cam it doesn't mean
it it doesn't matter yeah he is and
forever from here to four
we will be known as voltrick yeah yes
Diana Agron is in Burlesque they're like
so many low-key like [__] celebs in
that movie uh I feel like a lot of
people don't even realize Kristen Bell I
thought you were gonna say Christina
Aguilera no no of course you know
Christina Aguilera and Cher but like
Peter Gallagher Stanley Tucci Juliana
Juliana have Kristen Bell yeah
star-setted star-setted it's so good if
you've never seen burlesque today's the
day no if you've never seen burlesque
like that's not possible if you're
watching the show you've seen burlesque
I feel like it kind of didn't get it did
what it did it didn't but it's on
e-movies we love every weekend and if
you watch a show like you obviously
watch it do you know that e-movies we
love I believe they sound like the
Snippets that I've seen is making like
original movies now like hallmark-ish I
feel like you know once a quarter we
have this talk about ee how like I don't
need to talk I don't need to we like I
know that talk but I just want to get
your take on that they're doing original
movies because they were like doing like
a thing movies we love and it was all
these clips for movies I never saw so
people I never saw before and they're
trying to compete with like Netflix
Hallmark like original movies yeah and
but they're trying to make it seem like
movies we love and it's like movies
we've never seen or heard of no it
sounds like it's movies e-love like
because we don't know these movies don't
bring us into this who the [__] is we no
like I'm pretty sure that's what's
happening Eddie that is like tell anyone
that's a new level of sound they're just
pretending like it's movies we all love
but you haven't seen this one oh you're
missing out but everyone's seen it
yikes that's like e
like how he went I won't get into my
whole Spiel yeah yeah but like how he
went from like the network of the stars
with E news the Kardashians living low
hand pretty wild to what they are now is
so it's an ex like it is an example to
all other networks like don't do what he
did
they even canceled like daily pop and
nightly pop which were like the only two
even remotely relevant programs on their
network but I won't get into it great
because and then no kidding because we
need to get into our next story which is
brought to you by article oh sweet
summer is on the way have you been
dreaming up ideas for your outdoor space
and how to make the most of it well the
best thing about summer is getting to do
all your favorite activities outside
sharing meals watching movies falling
asleep on the sofa everything is better
Alfresco an article believes in
delightful design for every home and
thanks to their online only model they
have some really delightful pricing as
well their curated assortment of
mid-century modern Coastal industrial
scandi and boho designs make furniture
shopping simple articles team of
designers are all about finding the
perfect balance between style quality
and price they're dedicated to
thoughtful craftsmanship that stands the
test of time and looks good doing it the
best thing about article is that they're
exclusively online so like they're
shipping their pricing and their
delivery are on point it's like made for
the modern world I feel like so many of
these old school Furniture companies
it's like okay great well you'll see
your couch in eight months not with
article the pricing is fair the delivery
is good and it's all done really
seamlessly online they're knowledgeable
customer care team is there when you
need them to make sure that your
experience is smooth and stress-free
they offer fast affordable shipping
across the US and Canada plus they won't
leave you waiting around you pick the
delivery time and they will send you
updates every step of the way I feel
like I was actually at your house when
you had an article delivery recently and
it was like so like we did the toast and
you got the text and it was just like
seamless as hell so articles offering
Amber listeners 50 off your first
purchase of a hundred dollars or more to
claim visit article.com toast and the
discount will be automatically applied
at checkout that's article.com toast for
50 off your first purchase of a hundred
dollars or more thank you article for
sponsoring today's episode today's
episode is also brought to you by
Starbucks it's Starbucks Coffee
conveniently packaged for life on the go
so these Starbuck Starbucks ready to
drink coffee delivers and deliver an
uplifting boost that help you tune into
the moments that matter wherever you are
life moves fast so does Starbucks ready
to drink so they include a variety of
beverages from the bottled Frappuccino
coffee drink for a pop of flavor and
then their bold smooth Taste of the
Nitro cold brew the bottled Frappuccino
coffee drink is inspired by the
Starbucks cafe favorites and it comes in
four delicious flavors mocha vanilla
caramel and coffee for every moment you
can enjoy with Starbucks ready to drink
coffee so you know as a mother a
business owner we are gals on the go we
best be going we don't have time keeping
these stocked at your office at your
desk in your home and just grabbing one
is really a great way to stay
caffeinated throughout the day they're
so delicious it's a Starbucks drinks you
know and love but now you can get them
at home you can shop them the full line
online or in store they're available
wherever you buy groceries so it's
Starbucks coffee it's ready for right
now whenever you want to grab a
Starbucks frappuccino chilled coffee or
the Nitro cold brew there are so many
good choices based on your mood you know
are you feeling flirty are you feeling
bold whatever you're feeling there's a
drink for you so Starbucks coffee it's
ready for right now shop the full lineup
online or in store wherever you buy your
groceries and think Starbucks ready to
drink for sponsoring these next two
stories thank you so much you're welcome
so much our next story Kelly is coming
to New York what the Kelly Clarkson show
is moving across the country from the
universal lot in LA to 30 Rock okay but
I feel like this was like remember yeah
she's like a test she did like a week
here once yeah to celebrate like her new
season and we thought it was permanent
and we got we got the same old and now
I'm here to tell you it's permanent it's
permanent Kelly's gonna live in New York
I feel she's gonna live in Westchester
she's like with the kids like yeah who
knows oh my God I need to find out
everything yeah so for the past two
seasons her premiere week has filmed in
New York City but now she's taking her
show to the Big Apple for good the Kelly
Clarkson show will move production from
the universal lot in LA to NBC Studios
in 30 Rock in New York for next season
that's quite a promotion I feel like if
you're in 30 Rock like I feel like that
means the network is like really
invested in Kelly also I've learned from
this article that there's a new
expansion of a program called New York's
film tax credit which incentivizes
people to film here for tax benefits so
uh some shows are moving here a lot of
actual the daytime talk shows do film
out of New York now the talk in the
Jennifer Hudson show are like two that
are produced out of LA but the rest yeah
like Rachel Ray Is Here Yeah Drew
Barrymore Chevy Tamron Hall The View
Live with Kelly and Mark like everyone's
oh yeah you're right everyone's kind of
here they're making it beneficial tax
wise no but like the fact that they're
putting her in 30 Rock because I've been
to a bunch of the studios they're all
like along 12th Avenue they're not like
in the most premium parts of town down
Kelly getting top billing at 30 Rock is
exactly what she deserves 100 but not
even because we love her and like they
see her talent but because like she's in
the Allen slot she brought home like uh
11 Emmys I think oh wow and no her
ratings are killer eleven at Daytime
Emmy nominations and the show has
scooped up 13 trophies during its run
I'm so happy for Kelly and I just want
to know like what this is for us Kelly
what does this mean for us I feel like
Kelly's not in like her you know social
she's not gonna be like out and about at
fancy restaurants you're not gonna see
her at zero Bond no
no but you could see her at like a mommy
and me right so that's what I was gonna
say now it's on you to like find out
like where the kids wear are playing
even like her kids are older creepy what
I know we just like we need to meet
Kelly
we do I mean we should totally try and
go to her show well now that she's in
New York I feel like we can get tickets
just to watch but like Kelly in New York
City I feel like the city's gonna have a
different air about it it's gonna be
Buzzy and I feel like she should do like
a residency at Radio City
oh my God wait that's like low-key
brilliant because we're always saying
like how is she ever gonna juggle like a
real Nationwide tour with a daytime
Daily Talk Show like you film all day
every day Monday to Friday
Jerry Seinfeld has a residency at Beacon
Theater like people just come to him
she's at a place in her life where like
she's kind of gonna be like the face of
this town no no I love it and think
about think about judging think about
what this means at Christmas time
because New York is like the beacon of
Christmas cheer The Rock and she's at 30
Rock This is Kelly as is Kelly I feel
like we can get like a Kelly Christmas
Spectacular at Radio City yeah just
we're throwing some ideas of anybody
like works for Kelly like feel free to
take these yeah no I just give us people
from around the country would come to
New York City for if Kelly was like I'm
playing Radio City like once a week
indefinitely like they would come build
it and they will come yeah she did a
Vegas residency that was like short but
successful actually no did she ever get
to do it it's uh it's forthcoming sure
we had tickets it was before the
pandemic yeah no but it's like now with
her new album chemistry
um
the Vegas residency is a part of that
it's like back on she could take after
Vegas like bring that home yeah see how
ticket sales go yeah she's more popular
than ever especially now like her
divorce like there's like a lot of like
Scandal around it like there's it's
everything's coming up Kelly and her in
New York this is this is so exciting
it's really exciting for the city yeah
the city is kind of the Ambassador like
Kelly is to New York City but Shannon is
to spread it's like the Ambassador we
need no this is incredible this is wins
for everyone yeah I love it love it are
you ready for our fifth and final story
yeah a little young people romance drama
yprd why PRD because Braxton Barrios has
spotted with Tick-Tock star Alex Earl oh
after his wake up with Sophia Culpo oh
yeah I know I don't expect you to know
who Braxton Barrios I do I do a football
player no I do I do but he's a football
player for the Jets not anymore he uh no
actually you're right but he's always in
Miami oh because he's on the Dolphins
now great but I watched him get drafted
on the Culpo show and I thought he went
back to the Jets he but the cowboy show
might have been filmed like two years
ago no no because that takes a long time
like maybe got traded maybe okay
whatever
talk influencer Alex Earl who obviously
you do know it was seen hanging out with
NFL star Braxton Barrios after his
recent split from Sophia Culpo of the
Kobo show an eagle-eyed fan posted a
video on Friday of Alex and Braxton
standing on an outdoor patio of celeb
hot spots sedels in Miami the two stood
next to each other as he laughed and
chatted with a waiter while she met with
a fan and posed for photos
so it's clear that like they're together
from this video and they're both in town
for like the Grand Prix but also they
both live Grand Prix it's called F1
Formula One Miami Grand Prix you're like
nobody calls it the Grand Prix it's like
F1
I think we're calling it The Grand Prix
okay I think we're calling it The Grand
Prix
that's true okay there's three layers
today there's a lot of layers to this
because this isn't the first time I'm
hearing that like they were like so
there was speculation that Sophia
couple's boyfriend who's no offense like
this irrelevant football player and like
I just like a lot of girls think he's
cute but I don't think he's very good
um cheated on her cheated on her with
Alex Earl yes and there was actually
like a video going around from like one
of the couple girlies Instagram stories
where you can hear them talking about it
in the background thus kind of
confirming some of the rumors now
they're but they would never even
spotted together now they're like
officially spotted together that gives
Credence to the rumors that not only are
they dating but that they might have
overlapped with when her relationship
ended yeah which is not a good look for
for Alex or for Braxton no certainly not
for Braxton but it's so crazy because I
watched the couple show and like Braxton
and Sophia were so serious they were
moving in together like she literally
left Olivia she was living with Olivia
and she like literally all season was
like I have to tell Olivia moving out so
it's like the biggest deal but Sophia
was ready she's very uh snitch-like
um and she was like so excited honestly
I would thought at points watching the
show that Braxton and Sofia were going
to get engaged before Liberation and so
for them to like go from being so
serious to them not together at all like
I think Sophia has been devastated by it
she's talked a little bit about it but
obviously it's a lot
um
and now he's without I guess he's saving
Alex Earl this that's so tough like
honestly actually just I met Sophia Copa
for the first time at Stagecoach and
Aurora they were so nice
um like it was me and Margo and like it
was just very sisterly
um and it was great but this is so weird
and it just feels bizarre for like a
rumor now it's a come full circle and
now it's like true right yeah yeah maybe
now they feel like enough time has
passed where they can like go to stuff
together right and just like be dating
like why this guy also so randomly like
three years ago I actually sat next to
Olivia not Olivia Sophia and Braxton at
a restaurant like they walked in and
like we're seated right next to me in
Ben and I was like you know I know
everything did Ben know him no he's not
he's a jet he's not like by the way
being a jet is not some badge of honor
like is that they're like the worst team
now Aaron Rodgers is coming so maybe
they'll be relevant for a few years but
like it's like
oh you're a jet cool I'm a shark like
it's not like if there's a New York team
it's the Giants
okay they're both pretty like the same
no they're not they're yeah they're okay
but I'm telling you like I know sports
like they're not
I don't know I think I'd rather be a jet
I'd rather be a shark
um wait but something else I wanted to
talk about So Random there's been a lot
of speculation because like Alex Earl
has been blowing up and you know she's
never sat down for an interview did you
see she sat down for her first interview
and guess where it was you'll never
guess it was such a curveball but I
loved it
give me a Clues
we really love this person
podcast
no
TV no
magazine no
movie think you were on the right
trackish with podcast Radio yeah
Elvis Duran no bigger
Ryan Seacrest the biggest
in the radio Howard Stern yes
isn't that interesting it has it come
out yes yeah
and he like he did his research I think
he like probably someone on his team was
like we gotta get this girl he's like
what but they explained like how it's
going to be a big deal and he was like
really impressed by her she was very
very well spoken and it was you know
what it was so different I think a lot
of people were like she's gonna go and
call her daddy but I think in no world
would they ever would I should should
either one of them have gone on like I
don't think it would be good for Alex to
have her on I don't think it would be
good oh they're both named Alex
what is she gonna realize I don't think
we'll be good for Alex Cooper to have
Alex Earl on and I don't think it'd be
good for Alex Earl to be on Alex Cooper
like they're too similar I think like
it might pigeonhole Alex Earl to be like
bar stool like smoke show like I don't
think it would have been right for her
but where would she go and I never would
have thought Howard Stern but I thought
it was really an inspired choice that is
an inspired choice I want to listen to
the interview she looks great stuff on
demand yeah I think they're all on
YouTube he's like syndicated everywhere
it's not even it's like not even radio
anymore you know it's serious no like it
is but like the I saw the clips like all
over Clips but it's like six minute
Clips but I'm sure it's like an hour
thing yeah maybe I'm sure you can find
it somewhere that is interesting thank
you for sharing that I know
um speaking of the Jets though oh the
Knicks that's what I wanted to say yeah
last night that was your husband he was
like bereft I mean it was you have to be
don't cry because it's over smile
because it happened like the Knicks made
it to the second round of the playoffs
which hasn't happened in like 26 years
they made it to game they at least won a
game it's not like it was a total block
two games and I think they only won one
I the one I watched they won maybe I'm a
good luck charm it was just one they it
ended I think like when Julius Randle
stepped on the line he almost blew over
the team Julius Randle like was taking
it up like like a few times throughout
like all the games good thing you have
his phone number so you can tell him
that
because he's such a big Luke Combs fan
so Ben was was crushed but I think he
was also excited to have been a part of
something for so long yeah like if this
were any other season Ben would have
like have to stop watching the Knicks
like three months ago yeah so you know
what it's good it's good
and okay
it's the start you know they're in their
rebuilding era I mean they've been in
their rebuilding era for like 15 years
but it sounds like they're actually like
getting things built now right before
they were just like getting permits and
stuff yeah second round of playoffs
that's huge it's huge you have to be
grateful so the heat goes forward as to
the Lakers I have no [__] idea that's
my my knowledge of NBA is like just NYX
and then when do we get to the finals is
that next one is the Eastern Conference
Finals so it's like it's 14th left and
then two oh cool so it's the Heat versus
someone in the east
the Lakers for someone in the West
I think Rob is to the east clowns to the
West give you my sunshine give you my
best but the rain is always gonna come
when you're standing with me that's
really beautiful it is
and I think that's the best way to leave
the perfect note literally to leave
people with do you want to ask me how
I'm feeling
I I would have forgotten because you're
doing so well how are you feeling
amazing I'm so healed and guess what
it's lunchtime I know Jackie lunch time
the way like lunch has become the most
exciting part of my life is pathetic
come full circle just from when you were
a kid yeah
yeah yeah like yeah it's like lunch
period lunch greater than not lunch
couldn't have said about myself that's
the perfect note to end on
Monday Morning Show Oh quick
housekeeping
tomorrow Jackson cloud in studio
Thursday Audio Only I'll be reporting
live from Frisco Friday no episode your
girls traveling home and I'm just gonna
be real like I need a day off
um normalize taking days off yeah thank
you guys so much for listening to the
Tesla Monday morning to everybody Friday
I need to be watching this on YouTube
please don't forget to subscribe give
this video thumbs up available
standing in wickedly talented we are
hope you guys have a great day we'll see
you tomorrow I love ya bye bye